[Music]
oh hello
how are you i'm dave rubin enjoying a
fine cup of coffee this morning uh this
is the reuben report direct message on
march 2nd 2022 we are live streaming of
course on rumble youtube and blaze tv if
you have not subscribed to our rumble
channel please go ahead and do that
because
i'm fighting the system and the system
often bans people they don't like and
we've got to protect our digital assets
in these crazy times let me have just
another sip of coffee before i get to
the show today
hmm is that a dark roast
just delicious very exciting
all right guys um we're going to talk
about
joe biden today we're going to talk
about the state of the union i've calmed
down since last night as many of you
know i did live stream after the show
last night we only did it for about 20
minutes it involved tequila and emotion
uh it was hard to do it last night to be
quite honest with you it was actually
hard to recap that thing because it was
an hour-long
show it was like we're just in the show
must go on version of democracy where
nothing is real we all know it's theater
it's lie after lie it's erasure of truth
the rest of it and i i finished up last
night and i was like man either i did
not drink enough tequila or i drank too
much tequila but like what am i supposed
to do with this what are we all supposed
to do when we all know it's endless bs
would we all watch something and that
whether you like biden or hate biden or
somewhere or somewhere in between that
we're all just watching going ah can you
finish the sentence and yet nobody even
really talks about that so we're going
to do a full recap and then of course
we're going to cover the media reaction
which is really more ridiculous than
most of the things that biden said
although he's definitely into this war
thing now that we've moved on from covid
uh so to start i thought this would be
good we found a little compilation of
just the general slurs confusions and
mental breakdowns take a look putin may
circle keeve with tanks
but he'll never gain the hearts and
souls of the iranian people from
defending the russian ruble ruble
they're
invading the foreign country build a
wall high enough to keep out
a
a a a vaccine
the capacity of our economy
computer ships
all right it's just a small selection of
the slurs and confusions and you know i
by the way i say this to you guys all
the time i occasionally have to read off
a teleprompter here i never read my
thoughts off a teleport right i'm just
talking to you straight up right now
that's how i do this show but i do have
a teleprompter in front of me that i can
look at to give me the rundown of the
show that way i'm not staring down this
entire time and by the way sometimes
reading off a teleprompter can be
difficult but we all know that that's
not really what's going on here with
biden the scandal is the non-scandal we
know he's mentally breaking down it's
like
what are they what do they put in the
metamucil before they put him out there
like he was relative
relatively to
how he normally speaks
it was like that was pretty good it was
pretty good last night but he did have a
couple of those breakdowns now he
focused mostly on the uh upcoming war or
the war that is going on i should say
between russia and ukraine but clearly
the u.s is involved in one way or
another uh and we've moved on from kobit
so i thought instead of uh talking about
kovid today now that they've just
decided to wrap it up and i was warning
you guys just watch the trick right like
they're gonna do it just like that just
watch the trick and they'll all forget
about kovid because they have to get rid
of it to win in the midterms in a couple
months and they basically did it because
he did 40 minutes on the war before he
said anything about kovid so i thought
we will give kovid the respect that joe
biden gave it so here's joe biden this
is his last public appearance uh before
the state of the union so this is the
day before the state of the union it's
about a 30 or 40 second walk that he
took after he left the helicopter let's
throw to it and i'm just going to talk
through it here because here this is the
day before the state of the union and he
does have an interesting way of walking
which some people have connected to some
uh
mental related stuff uh but putting that
aside for a moment he's wearing a mask
outside alone for absolutely no reason
there is 100 certainty that when he got
when he was in the helicopter he was not
wearing a mask he puts it on for show
walks outside with the mask completely
alone and then if he makes it into the
oval office or wherever he's going over
here if he can follow the path correctly
then he obviously takes the mask off
when he's around other people and that's
really all i'm going to say about kovid
they've wrapped it up they've wrapped it
up so the choice is yours now you can
keep wearing masks you can keep being
mean to people uh you can keep injecting
yourself you can keep calling for people
to be fired and all that stuff but
they've moved on and you gotta give the
devil as due they did it right in front
of us they did the magic trick right in
front of us and here we are so mostly we
will be talking about war today the new
thing on the table
and uh and the media reaction to war uh
before i get to all that i want to talk
to you guys about moik you know you hear
that that's the tantalizing sound of
meat sizzling on the grill i like
knowing exactly where my meat comes from
and with moic that place is from small
family farms all across the country you
can help save the family farm and get
access to the highest quality meat on
earth when you join the moyk movement
today
moyk delivers fresh grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and sustainable wild
caught alaskan salmon straight to your
door more farmers farm like our
grandparents did and as a result point
taste meat meat tastes like it should
and is a difference you can taste
because the family farm does it better
you can feel good knowing you're helping
family farms stay financially
independent too you choose the meat
delivered in every box like rib eyes to
chicken breasts to pork chops pork chops
to salmon place and much more plus you
can cancel any time david and i recently
smoked some of their bone-in rib eyes
and they were absolutely delicious shark
tank host kevin o'leary called moyk's
bacon the best bacon he's ever tasted
and ring doorbell founder jamie simonoff
jumped at the chance to invest in moic
plus they guarantee you'll say oink oink
i'm just so happy i got miked i know
that i do and you will too keep american
farming going by signing up at
mointbox.com
reuben right now and listeners of this
show get a free filet mignon for a year
get free filet mignon for a year not
just uh filet mignon free filet mignon
whole year that's one of the best uh
filet mignon mignons you'll ever taste
but for a limited time spelled moink m o
i n k box.com reuben that's moicbox.com
reuben and now back to me okay so what
i'm more interested in talking about
than really the substance of what joe
biden talked about because it was mostly
nonsense it was mostly nonsense it was
like projecting this american strength
and trying to scare russia while also
saying we're not going to war with
russia but we're going to do all these
things that are going to scare russia
and russia is a nuclear power so maybe
they'd get nervous and escalate a war
it was mostly about that kind of stuff
then there was a bunch of lying about
the economy as i said he just sort of
glossed over the coven thing we're
moving past it yippity-dippity
um but what i'm more interested in is
the media reaction because that is now
the lens with which all of us see all of
this stuff that's why you watch this
show so that you can go about your daily
life and if you watch this you watch for
a little bit maybe you watch the full
show i hope and then you have a little
bit of information and you can take that
into your life you can incorporate it
however you see fit you can have
conversations and understand things
sensibly unfortunately because we don't
have an honest media anymore and the
corporate press has just become
basically cheerleaders for the democrats
and cheerleaders for war when it's their
guy who wants war and everything else
it's like it's impossible basically for
the average person to make sense of any
of this so as i was watching
the recaps it was like i don't know that
i live on the same planet as these
people so here's cnn
correspondent van jones and people
always describe van jones to me when
they say dave you're hitting the
liberals too hard you know dave you were
a liberal you're hitting the liberals
too hard there's good liberals out there
there's their bill maher they got that
barry weiss and the third one they
always tell me is van jones these are
the big three libs that are not
completely insane according to most
people well here's van jones assessment
of that speech last night and just tell
me like do i live on the same planet as
this person
first of all i thought that was joe
biden at his best uh uncle joe is back i
thought he was he was being
the leader listen nobody believes in
these american ideals more than joe
biden it showed tonight
he had spent his entire career standing
for american unity at home he stood for
that and for american ideals abroad and
i thought listen i have not seen unity
in this country like i saw at the
beginning of that speech and i don't
want to step on that it is very very
important that we underscore to the
world that every single person stood
with joe biden tonight every republican
stood on their feet and and the
ukrainians are not but not by themselves
listen i was impressed with the energy i
was impressed with if you didn't believe
in democracy before if you never heard
democracy and you just looked at the
body language of this guy this guy
believed every word he said and i think
i'm proud tonight we have a leader like
him
like i don't know am i on a completely
different planet as that person
maybe like or one of us should be
institutionalized and i'm pretty sure
it's not me like everything he said
there was nonsense man did you watch the
speech
let's just go through some of what you
said joe biden was at his best well we
already went through the slurs and the
confusion
and all of that kind of stuff so at his
best i don't know what you mean by at
his best everyone knows like you don't
have to be a conservative or republican
or anything he's no longer at his best
obviously right like it's just obvious
uh that's number one uh he talks about
uncle joe we got uncle joe back yeah
uncle joe who sniffs little girl's hair
like who uncle joe with the the kids the
black kids who play with his leg hair
remember that and corn pop on the other
side of the field and he was a bad dude
and all that i don't know who uncle joe
is fine all right you're trying to be
folksy um
nobody believes in american ideals more
than joe biden it's funny i didn't hear
joe biden talking about freedom i didn't
hear him talking about liberty i didn't
hear him talking about states rights i
didn't hear him talking about the
sovereignty of the individual i didn't
hear him talking about any of that stuff
i talked i heard him talking endlessly
about giant government programs where
act which are actually antithetical to
what america is really about it's
completely congruent with what they're
turning america into
but i just don't even know what that
means nobody believes in american ideals
more than joe biden nobody
i think there's a lot of people who do
they just don't get air time on your
silly network then he talks about unity
there was so much freaking unity
everybody was standing and clapping and
it's like no not true i saw the same
video that you did and the republicans
did not clap for a lot of this by the
way the democrats used to not clap for a
lot of trump stuff this is partisan
politics it's just what it is i just
don't know what you're talking about
unity
unity around a war i mean yes war is
good to get everyone crazy right the fog
of war we all start getting nuts and
people who can't tie their shoes
straight and don't have jobs suddenly
are like yes let's bomb russia like
there is a way that it kind of gets
behind us and it fuels us like rooting
for a team so i guess there's something
there and then the body language thing i
mean no
joe joe's body language is not good he's
he's stiff he's obviously full of botox
and fillers and kind of creepy and the
big smile every time he smiles one eye
closes so he's like
like like like this you know because the
botox whatever it is is put and he's got
the egg teeth and the teeth are fake and
i and
it's like i don't know what you mean by
the body language like i just have no
idea what you're talking about so that's
van jones and again he's thought of as a
smart decent he's a moderate he's a
liberal he's not a crazy banana's
leftist but he just watched a speech and
it has nothing to do
with the speech that i saw
but speaking of people who watch a
speech and don't really see it the way i
see it there's this crazy alcoholic
woman named nancy pelosi and she she was
sitting behind biden during this thing
and he was talking about soldiers
bringing in toxic smoke and she really
got a kick out of it
faced in afghanistan face many dangers
one being stationed at bases breathing
in toxic smoke from burn pits
many of you have been there
i've been out
what
can we do it again let's do it here
afghanistan face many dangers
one being stationed at bases breathing
in toxic smoke from burn pits
many of you have been there
[Applause]
i love toxics
what is wrong with these people there's
something wrong with all of them don't
you see it can't you all see
something is wrong with these robotic
soulless weirdos what is go what sorry
one more time like what what is this
that face many dangers
one being stationed in bases breathing
in toxic smoke from burn pits yes
many of you have been there
all right um
at the end of the speech uh joe said go
get him that was the big finish of the
thing and it became unclear to people
what he meant by that because uh
normally it's you know god bless america
okay i'm out of here go get him what did
he mean by that even nbc
the propagandists at nbc even they were
a little confused by what that meant
i also think there was a strange moment
at the end where he said go get him that
was audible to the audience and we're
not quite sure what he means i think
he's talking about vladimir putin and
the bad guys over there but
it was an ad-lib that
kind of yeah normally his clothes god
bless god bless him that was soldiers i
think he was trying to buck up america
and say we're strong the state of the
union is strong get out there and you
know
remember that we are strong as americans
by the way his covenant
don't worry guys he just said some
random statement at the end uh but no
this is what he meant because they they
carry water for him right they carry
water for the administration i think he
meant vladimir putin and the bad guys
sounds like a band in brooklyn in 1987
doesn't it vlad putin and the bad guys
putin and the bad guys they're a real
hipster band
it's like what did he mean by that he
just blurted outside did he mean go get
him like go kill putin
let's get the nuclear war going like
what is he actually talking about
doesn't matter nobody knows he must mean
this because he's obviously not having
some sort of mental breakdown
then this morning this one's from this
morning although there was plenty of
stuff going on last night jen sake the
white house press secretary she had a an
accidental slip up maybe even two
slip-ups here i believe this is from cnn
take a look you know i was at the state
department the president was the vice
president the last time russia invaded
ukraine this is a pattern of horror from
this president from president putin and
from the cronies around him
all right so first off this is a pattern
of horror from this presidency she fixed
that okay we all misspeak sometimes fine
but uh lady i think you accidentally
said the quiet part owl out there yeah
there's a pattern here
putin seems to invade on biden's watch
he was the vp
when putin did it last time now he's the
p
he was vp now he's p you see what's
going on here there is a pattern there
that putin does bad things when he
thinks that we have incompetent people
who don't actually live up to their
words and set their red lines and set
order in the world uh then he does some
bad stuff when we've got those type of
people involved and and guys remind me i
can't remember i'm thinking about this
one it's driving me crazy there was a
guy
who was president uh for four years in
between when uh when biden was vp and
when he was p
do you have any recollection of who that
was uh any of you guys he was
he was
yes orange man remember orange man
scary racist white supremacist orange
man for some reason that pattern that
sake is talking about the pattern was
broken during orange man i don't know i
don't have my abacus here to figure it
all out but something seems weird about
that uh there was more from nvc though
stephanie rule
uh actually acknowledged that biden's
inflation crisis is a problem although
there's a little little trickery that
she does right up top which we'll get to
take a look president biden has a
complicated economic story to tell while
he has some very big wins six and a half
million jobs created unemployment now
down to four percent and household
savings hitting a record high as we come
out of the pandemic those are very big
wins unfortunately for this
administration they're discounting
because the inflation that we're facing
right now is a huge problem for the
american people we see it all over the
place and it's not going to get any
better any time soon because of the
situation in ukraine now it's no
surprise the gop's response was
hammering inflation over and over but
frankly they didn't even need to do that
the american people are feeling it every
single day it's what they're talking
about at their kitchen tables and it's
what's causing a problem in approval
ratings for president biden
okay as you know i try to give the devil
as due
and uh they lie but sometimes they
actually say something somewhat true and
uh she did there she the second half of
that she was getting to it okay the
guy's got some problems fair enough but
the top half of that that's where they
confuse them because she's like it's a
win
that uh 6.5 million people are uh are
unemployed was it 6.5 unemployed
6.5 unemployed right um and then she
does this thing what was the other part
oh that unemployment is down no no it
was six points sorry it was 6.5 million
new jobs not 6.5 million people are
unemployed 6.5 million new jobs now of
course she doesn't tell you that it's
because they locked everybody down that
the jobs went up this year as things
sort of opened up which is exactly what
the next number that she gave was that
unemployment is less than it was last
year which is the exact same thing so
even when they're trying to tell you
something true that we all have
no we all know about this unemployment
uh this inflation problem like they
still sort of lie in the way that they
frame it okay is what it is chuck todd
who uh is another nbc guy uh he really
wanted uh joe to
talk more about ukraine let me put it
this way in in some ways
for the sake of the ukrainians i hope we
don't say it didn't you know i hope we
say oh
it was about right but i fear
this is going to feel like a speech that
didn't age well because of the lack of i
thought he'd spend more time in ukraine
spend a little more time
explaining why it is our fight as you
said good versus evil explain what
a little bit more and a little bit of
the history of the defense of europe and
a little bit of how why we're in this
position why we have these alliances
what what it all means
and
it just felt like an abrupt end
after the 12 minutes of that and it felt
like boy we could have had more
there was more to say i think there was
more that the public would have and then
it turned look i do think he
accomplished two important pieces of
politics
saying the phrases secure our borders
and fund our police there are a lot of
vulnerable democrats and a lot of uh
house and senate races that are relieved
to hear the leader of the democratic
party say those two phrases
okay first off more time on ukraine the
whole beginning the whole heart of this
thing was about ukraine and basically
threatening russia okay that's what it
was that's not me defending russia you
can't just attack another sovereign
nation okay russia bad right now putin
not the good guy
but more time chuck do you know that
this was the american state of the union
what is the state of our union what is
the situation that we got going right
now and if you ask the average person
who's watching inflation grow
go up who's watching critical race
theory in their kids schools and the
mass and all the stuff where do you
think ukraine fits into this that is not
to say it is not
important to do what we can to help
western democracies
and we can have all sorts of discussions
about that which we don't do
particularly well but in the state of
our union that thing is not on the top
10 list and he spent most of the time
talking about it then he got to uh chuck
said well he did do pretty good on uh
funding the police and securing the
border now it's funny because uh there
was another guy and guys could you help
me out again on this one there was this
other guy with the with the uh who
wanted to fund the police and and take
care of the borders uh what color orange
guy again remember that guy that's what
he was always talking about and of
course people thought he was racist for
giving money to the police making sure
we had law and order and making sure
that we had a secure border uh but biden
did call
to fund the police let's take a look the
answer is not to defund the police
it's to fund the police
fund
fund them
fund them with resources and training
resources and training they need to
protect their communities
i asked democrats and republicans alike
to pass my budget and keep our
neighborhoods safe
that's pretty funny that's pretty funny
because i remember that lady behind him
uh kabala harris talking about defunding
the police i remember that other lady
behind him nancy pelosi talking about
defunding the police i mentioned i can
mention and uh remember plenty of people
that did that and they were all clapping
right there the people that have been
calling to defund the police and you're
not going to believe this on the
internet
there is video and people splice things
together using computers to show the
hypocrisy take a look so we've been
talking about defunding the police
there's some issues that we ask police
to do like mental health issues or
policing in schools and all the rest
that perhaps we can
shuffle some of that money around suck
it up defunding the police has to happen
we need to defund the police mayor eric
garcetti saying take some of the money
from policing about 150 million dollars
i applaud eric garcetti for doing what
he's done not only do we need to
disinvest
foreign police but we need to completely
dismantle the minneapolis police
department so yes defund your butts
defund you yes i support the
reallocation of resources
from nypd we will be moving funding from
the nypd to youth initiatives and social
services they are talking about reducing
the allocation of resources to that
department and i think every single
city in this country ought to be
thinking about the same thing yes i
support the defund movement i'm for
responsible
reallocation of resources and defund the
police i think you do all those other
things you don't need all the money
that's going in the police department so
yeah i mean the spirit of it i i do
support that there's no reason the
police budget should just keep growing
and growing and growing
they can make sensible cuts to policing
we propose to redirect over seven
million dollars from the police bureau
that our city through our city
administrative officer identified 250
million dollars
in cuts proceeded to leave tweeting no
more policing incarceration and
militarization it can't be reformed when
they're saying defund the police what
are they saying
they're saying we want fundamental basic
change when it comes to policing
uh and they're right
all right the full version of that video
is seven minutes we spliced about two
minutes for you look those are all
democrats those are all people who have
destroyed
the cities that they were elected to
protect and to lead whether it's new
york whether it's minneapolis whether
it's seattle or portland or l.a or san
francisco you guys know it right so this
is what the heart of the democrats has
been doing for two years they destroyed
our cities
the cities are still destroyed so now
joe is going well well hot damn i might
lose my majority in the congress we got
a problem here there's an election
coming and people are realizing that
when you defund the police that you get
more crime and then when you get more
crime you're not going to believe this
well then people decide to leave and
then there's a mass exodus from
california where 400 000 people leave
california and now live in texas and in
tennessee and in florida and a couple
other states so they they create all the
problems and then they pretend it had
nothing to do with them and this is why
i've been saying to you for the last
week or so we cannot forget what these
people have done whether it was covid
and masks and mandates and firing people
unjustly
uh whatever or banning people on social
media or lying about defunding the
police once they were the ones that did
it they will have everyone in october
believing the complete opposite of the
truth and you cannot forget it so all
that being said is it good now
perhaps
that joe biden or whoever writes his
speech or whoever is you know filling
them up with the adderall concoction is
it good
that they basically are like boy we do
realize that this thing is bad and we've
destroyed a lot of these cities and we
shouldn't be defunding the police
anymore and we should fund the police
and get nancy and kamala to stand for it
i suppose that is good right like that
means that maybe they're going to
reverse some of this stuff now my
personal belief also is that the entropy
in these cities towards the destruction
of these places is still coming you've
taught a generation of young people or
brainwashed a generation of young people
to believe that police are racist that
the systems are all racist and
everything else so if you start funding
the police again they'll come after
those people who are trying to get the
revolution going in the first place i
mean the beauty of the revolution is it
always eats its own right so it will eat
bernie it will eat aoc it will eat ilhan
and talib and the rest of them and i'll
have a nice glass of uh what do i have
i think a chianti would be nice while i
watch it happen um
but i guess on its face it is good that
they're gonna now reverse that policy
the problem is
they're gonna trick people into thinking
that it was never their policy in the
first place and we cannot forget it what
that might signal a little bit more is
that maybe there'll be a little more of
a fight between the progressive
lunatics and this mostly insane moderate
democrats i mean they really don't exist
anymore but maybe there's a little
tension there and i do think that that
tension would be good but just don't
forget guys that's the main point don't
forget because they get up there like
how soulless do you have to be to be a
kamala harris standing up
and applauding after you were one of the
people that was bailing out rioters
during the blm stuff two years ago
nancy pelosi you're talking about
defunding the police you're a
congresswoman in the san francisco area
san francisco is a [ __ ] hole
emphasis on [ __ ] because there's
literally an app that will tell you
where human feces is so that you don't
step on it when you're walking literally
it is an actual app that you can
download but these people then get up
and applaud uh for the reversal of the
same things that they brought in it's uh
it's quite extraordinary uh guys got one
more ad for you and then we're gonna
finish up strong here uh did biden's
state of the union make you nauseous
that's a segway uh if so you're not
alone one out of three americans
regularly suffer from nausea or anxiety
and if you're one of them you know how
quickly your body can turn from
comfortable to crisis mode and this is
why you've got to check out relief band
relief band is the number one fda
cleared anti-nausea wristband that has
been clinically proven to relieve and
prevent nausea and vomiting associated
with motion sickness anxiety migraines
hangovers morning sickness chemotherapy
and so much more relief band is a band
you wear on your wrist that stimulates a
nerve in the wrist that travels to the
part of the brain that controls nausea
blocking the signal your brain is
sending to your stomach telling you that
you are sick you simply change the
intensity depending on how you're
feeling to make it stronger or weaker
the technology was originally developed
in hospitals to relieve patients but now
through relief band it's available to
the masses the products 100 drug free
non-drowsy and provides all-natural
long-lasting relief with zero side
effects for as long as needed their
newest model relief band sport is
waterproof has an extended battery life
and can attach to your apple or android
watch relief band makes a great gift for
any time of the year right now they've
got an exclusive offer just for the
reuben report audience if you go to
reliefman.com and use promo code ruben
you'll receive 20 off plus free shipping
and a no questions asked 30 day money
back guarantee that's the best offer
you're going to find for relief band
anywhere but you have to use my code so
head on over to r e l i e f b a and d
dot com slash reuben no use my promo
code ruben for twenty percent off plus
free shipping and now back to me i don't
know what's going to happen if you go to
reliefband.com
and maybe it'll work but use code ruben
it will definitely work uh anyway i
thought we would end on this
i think i've laid out a case
it's a depressing case
it makes you wonder what the hell's
really going on here
but i want it to end on hope and the
hope is that joe biden will not be
president forever right
he's old
the ideas aren't great things are
cyclical
good guys come around and win over time
and uh there's a great woman behind him
her name's kamala harris
see what i did there sorry about that
this is a poor ending
uh kamala two days ago right before the
state of the union uh here's her on a
radio show trying to explain to the
masses what's happening in russia and
tell me is this the woman who you want
one heartbeat away from the presidency
or someone who maybe maybe should be
teaching kindergartners but probably not
really if you're watching any level of
news even social media you're seeing
everything that's going on right now in
the ukraine break it down to layman's
terms for people who don't understand
what's going on and how can this
directly affect the people of the united
states so
ukraine is a country in europe it exists
next to another country called russia
russia is a bigger country russia is a
powerful country russia decided to
invade a smaller country called ukraine
so
basically that's wrong
lord help us
lord help us one heartbeat away from the
presidency i mean the woman has no
understanding of anything as i always
tell you she was polling at zero percent
in her own party
when the powers that be told joe to
select her
and she talks and
and conveys information
like a complete idiot like oh my
russia's big
ukraine's small that's bad you can't do
that
here's kamala also two days ago on
election outcomes and what are they
juicing her with with the shakes take a
look
because as we all know elections matter
and when folks vote they order what they
want and in this case they got what they
asked for
[Applause]
i went off script a little bit
remember when harry met sally i'll have
what she's having like i don't want
whatever she's having like what they've
whatever they've got her on they've got
biden on something they've got her on
something and she's constantly doing
this and she's shaking the arms and they
got what they wanted we did the election
and okay
yeah
lordy lordy lordy um
let's do the locals comments first and
then we'll jump over to the final video
we got a funny one for you at the end uh
nick over at
rubinreport.locals.com says the european
media are saying biden looked weak and
incoherent in the state of the union
yeah i saw a couple things out of
australia i saw some stuff out of the uk
that that was the main take actually the
video that we showed you uh the
compilation of the slurs that we showed
you right up top that was from sky news
australia so yes we don't have an honest
news media to assess this stuff and that
is part of the problem so it wouldn't
surprise me if the take that the average
person is getting in europe is
vastly different than what the average
person is getting here in america rhonda
says i only buy groceries and gas now no
more leisure shopping
um
that's i mean
i get it i get it that's a depressing
take on reality um
you know we're well stocked here i think
everyone should be stocking up i don't
think you have to be like a full-on
prepper but i think being prepared for
more problems related to the supply
chain and gas lines and whatever else
could be coming down the pike if the war
was to go hot whatever it is like it
doesn't feel like things are very stable
right now so i think you know look
before covid everyone would make fun of
preppers right and then everyone became
preppers during cobin so that doesn't
mean you have to build a bunker
underneath your house but i wouldn't
blame you for doing that either
but you should
take whatever precautions are necessary
which means probably having some more
canned food in your house and everything
else which again we do here
and
it's just it's just a sad state of
reality on that front zoe says every
current problem in the united states
today has been created by biden um
i don't know if every single one has
been created by him but if you if you
look at it broadly i mean look the guy's
been in public life public office for i
think now 48 years
when he was vice president for eight
years under barack obama why did he not
solve any of these things he talks about
whole new a whole new set of things
right now that why did barack obama not
solve systemic racism and the rest of it
actually one thing i will give biden
credit for he didn't go bananas on the
racism stuff he didn't call too many
people racist last night so that was
that was pretty nice
um
but you know yes guys like him i would
say
are the ones that have created so many
of these problems these people who get
everything wrong i mean the the defund
the police thing is the perfect example
of that all of these people up there
applauding oh no we're going to fund the
police but you're the ones who created
the problem in the first place but then
through the media and the way the
machine operates by the time election
time comes around people don't remember
and they're like no it is the democrats
who want to fund the police i don't know
who did who wanted to defund the police
who were what are you crazy
so that's what we're up against and
that's what we got to figure out how to
how to do a better job to communicate
that no these are the people who did all
of that nonsense
and finally we are going to do a cold
close to the show today uh we played
this one last night but this is i mean
this is legitimately like it's hilarious
it's perfect it's the right way to end a
show
action news 4 in pittsburgh yesterday
had a little problem with their chiron
take a look it's not clear what may have
been taken and no arrests have been made
a 71-year-old man is accused of
inappropriately touching a 12-year-old
girl at the walmart in west mifflin
sunday